[Musique]
il faut dire merci et un vrai plaisir
tfou costaud tu me ramènes un rôle trop
content après voilà c'est s'érode je te
parlais depuis des semaines la séquence
mais ça fait toujours mal à l'avouer ça
fait six mois le procès chose
s'échauffera attend
les rapports avec jean basset petit du
film à cannes j'ai
passé ma vie c'est mon biopic il ya
marques extérieures ou de prison son
biopic là tu connais pas mon passé frère
j'ai eu des démêlés avec la justice à
l'époque je me suis tapé avec des
vieilles femmes bref on sait pas qui est
basé au caire mais juste moi je
comprends pas je joue conte d'hans backe
hymne jimmy choo mon rôle ma vie quoi
donc moi je joue 3 bah ouais c'est ça
que je crois qu un meuble pour un beau
prend un vrai plan mais je suis et que
je perds mon temps tu rigoles maintenant
je crois pas qu'ils me tuent j'ai pas je
suis pas de jouer toi mais pourquoi
comme pour thoiras qui quoi les épaules
gras pour aiguiser fusil frérot qui soit
content
d'offrir au regard de quoi servent tous
les matins maquilleuse m fait le mp un
trou ici tout là bas peut-être une
histoire de lunettes je sais pas
l'histoire du net ces histoires de l'adn
du chromosome cruise mais sont hors du
regard
salut excellent
lé scooter j'adore les pissenlits et les
fleurs de lotus est excellent super et
mathieu tu fait bien plaisir et c'est
moi qui m'arrêtent un froid tu en fais
tu veux quoi pour de vrai temps très
beau dire que j'ai pas le temps parce
que je recherchais mais tout est beau
cet acte en train de dire la non je te
parle pas ça ne semble pas je rêve là
franchement bien croire je te dise
acheter nassima thème la tête haute at
on aussi ma tante autant très je vais te
dire un truc que personne n'osait dire
jusqu'à présent frère tu sais que tout
ce qu'ils pensent de toi cinéma français
tout le monde dit un acteur éclaté tu as
de la chance juste et beau
parce que tu crois que c'est pas que
vecteur le plus flagrant du cinéma
français au moins là bas je devais faire
la téléréalité prix est d'accord
j'aimerais mandat personnes alors que
samba c'est le coup d'oeil et peut-être
l'ombre oublier la lazio pour les plus
redoutables quoi bein je te la vérité
je trouverai quelqu'un d'autre toutou
faire ce film non c'est tout le monde
voudrait faire ce film je retrouvais
plein d'autres des têtes
non je peux pas c'est bon on a senti un
vrai scénario
[Musique]